as you've been watching Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg is still testifying
before lawmakers on Capitol Hill tonight
right now the hearings in a short break
Zuckerberg spent much of the afternoon
repeatedly falling on his
multibillion-dollar sword in front of
senators anxious to be seen as defending
the privacy rights of their constituents
a long day of testimony some interesting
exchanges chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel has the
latest tonight from the hill good
evening Mike well Brett good evening to
you Mark Zuckerberg says he is open to
making changes to Facebook and the tech
CEO says the buck stops with him we
didn't take a broad enough view of our
responsibility and that was a big
mistake
and it was my mistake and I'm sorry the
stakes are incredibly high for Mark
Zuckerberg Facebook has an estimated 2.2
billion users and he's facing lawmakers
for the first time after it was revealed
87 million users have their data
unknowingly shared with Cambridge
analytic a we considered it a closed
case in retrospect that was clearly a
mistake we shouldn't have taken their
word for it and we've updated our
policies and how we're going to operate
the company to make sure that we don't
make that mistake again
some senators warned Facebook better fix
it or Congress will let me just cut to
the chase if you and other social media
companies do not get your act in order
none of us are gonna have any privacy
anymore
the line of questioning bounced around
during the hearing as some Democrats
focused on when Zach or Berg and his
team knew about Russian attempts to
influence the 2016 election the campaign
included ads and false information to
create discord and harm
secretary Clinton's campaign and the
content was seen by an estimated 157
million Americans the Facebook CEO
talked about efforts to make sure that
never happens again the nature of these
attacks though is that you know there
are people in Russia whose job it is is
to try to exploit our systems and other
internet systems and other systems as
well so this is an arms race I mean
they're gonna keep on getting better at
this and we need to invest in keeping on
getting better at this to Texas senator
Ted Cruz asked Zuckerberg in facebook
was guilty of media bias are you aware
of any ad or page that has been taken
down from Planned Parenthood senator I'm
not but let me just move on another work
sorry about moveon.org
I'm not specifically aware of those
about any Democratic candidate for
office I'm not specifically aware I mean
I've I'm not I'm not sure Zuckerberg was
greeted on Capitol Hill with
approximately 100 giant cardboard
cutouts of him wearing a t-shirt saying
fix Facebook Zuckerberg confirmed for
the first time that Facebook has been
working with Special Counsel Robert
Muller's probe the CEO says he has not
personally spoken with members of
Muller's team Brett
welcome and just outside the hearing my
thank